I just remember always being demonically
attacked then lost control of my body
and a demon possessed my body he stood
in the window and she said the whole
room was
burning but uh there was no no fire so
the demons were she was awake showing
showing it to her something like that
and uh I had to uh take her off of the
the the window and uh otherwise she
would haveed jumped and then like I was
literally it was literally like there
was a puppet
master just using me and I was the
puppet and like it was like it was so
demonic seen this guy in the dorm at
night walk through walls holding a
fetish oh and so he had demonic power
Jesus comes and he says the Lord rebuke
thee of Satan which means that uh you
know when we use Bible texts we can
command these demons to leave right in
the name of Jesus and so we can claim
Zechariah 3:2 and say Lord you know the
demons are attacking me uh I claim
Zechariah 3:2 the Lord rebuke thee Oh
Satan in the name of Jesus I command you
evil spirits to leave mhm right and they
have to leave mhm if you have that
sincerity of heart and you're dealing
with your open doors um they will
leave warning this episode may contain
content that is not suitable for
children your discretion is advised tell
us a little bit about your background um
you guys are involved in ministries and
you have things going on give us a
little bit of what you do yeah sure so
we're from Malaysia we have been for the
last 11 years running a b school over
there uh called sea salt now uh
Southeast Asian uh Soul winning and
Leadership training uh and we have um we
as every year we have about 20 to 30
students that come through
people of all ages and many of them go
into Bible work uh and we mobilize Bible
worker teams to do Church plants uh
throughout uh quala lumor how long is
that program uh the program is 4 and a
half months okay and uh we um you know
the the young people come through or the
students come through and they have a
Revival and reconversion experience uh
and many of them change the trajectory
of their lives after that as they go go
into Bible work uh after a year or two
they decid to go full-time into Ministry
so slowly we've been building a bigger
and bigger team of Bible workers and uh
you know dividing off uh new Bible
workers off into teams that will do
Church plants in U unreached territories
around quala lumor and you know I don't
think um people understand like what
goes on with Bible work um you know
they're like oh that's nice you study
the Bible but after listening to your
guys' stories I mean honestly you have
seen more spiritual warfare than
probably 90% of Christianity you know
what I mean like I I have not seen what
you are about to ready to talk about and
um you know what a what a an important
job that you're doing I mean to
me that's that's where it's at what's a
dominant um religious environment that
you're in yeah so we have three main
races in Malaysia uh the the dominant
race would be Malay Malay are Muslim um
legally uh so they don't have a choice
in the matter if you're born Malay
you're Muslim interesting and uh it's
legal for you to is there problems if
you change or can you change there is so
we're not allowed to reach out to uh
Muslims in Malaysia that's illegal uh
the other two races would be the Chinese
who are predominantly uh Buddhist or
taist and than um Indian who are uh
Hindus what if they reach out to you is
that illegal for them or illegal for you
or it's illegal all around all around it
doesn't matter yeah and there's one more
group I I would say are the indigenous
people I missed them out uh my wife
would be really upset with me for
missing them out uh that would be the
Head Hunter tribes in sabba and sarak
who are also considered indigenous
people uh and they're in that um Sy
Society there's a lot of Witchcraft so
usually within the family somewhere you
would have a witch doctor uh that's as
part of that community and so a lot of
the students that come to us because
sabba and sarak are the Christian States
in
Malaysia um so so Malaysia was formed
out of a coalition of uh sabba sarak and
then the mainland Peninsula uh Malaya uh
and also Singapore but then they split
off so government just basically left
them alone I mean if they're indigenous
essentially they were there first
they're also Malaysian but does the
government consider them Muslim as well
they don't they just say whatever your
own thing that's right yeah so that's
why they're predominantly Christian
state so more uh throughout for the
Bible School more of the the young
people come from sabba and sarak to a
Bible school and so uh the Lord knew
that when I needed to with my wife have
to this experience because he he was
going to start to bring more and more
kids who were experiencing or had grown
up with witchcraft and uh spiritual
warfare all around them so this is not
new for a lot of kids like seeing demons
um you know my wife as she grew up uh it
was normal for her to see demons wow and
when you say head hunting tribes like
are they really hunting each other's
heads like I'm half I'm actually half
indigenous and uh my my grandfather was
a head hunter wow what does that mean
like they take your head they they kill
the enemies so it's like the trophy if
they kill their enemies they will get
their heads they will hang it in their
house as a trophy oh my goodness like in
Tennessee they hang like mooses and
things on the wall yeah do you would
hang like their enemy's head oh wow
theide house they from a different
culture and my grandfather used to you
know play with a lot of black magic and
how they defend themsel in the war now I
do know the definition of black magic if
you look it up in the whipster
dictionary it's the invocation of evil
spirits for evil purposes and that is
like that's scary whenever I hear Black
Magic being entered into it it's like
you know you're messing with demons and
and that's interesting right so tell us
a little bit about your wife and um you
know this is where this story kind of
begins to unfold for you how you got
into the current work that you're doing
so um tell us a little bit about this
sure uh so my wife is similar to Sabrina
half Chinese and half uh indigenous um
so her mom is uh from indigenous uh
tribes and then her dad is
Chinese um and her grandmother was a
witch doctor wow and so growing up she
would see her grandmother uh making
charms casting
spells um you know just normal everyday
life for them uh seeing uh her
grandmother gather other witches
together to create charms to cell to
people and this was quite normal for and
this stuff affects Generations right I
mean like if it starts in a generation
back there like this I mean you might
even know your great-grandparent messed
with this stuff and you're dealing with
it that's right if you look at the end
of the second commandment uh you know
God says the sins of the fathers will be
unto the third and the fourth generation
so growing up um my wife was able to see
demons as I said wow they wouldn't
communicate with her but all her and all
of her cousins all grew up being able to
see things I mean is it just like that
becomes normal like all of a sudden it's
like there's big shadowy guy right there
did they have any specific instructions
for the family like you're to live this
way eat these things don't eat these
things you know not really I've heard of
that happening before in certain
indigenous tribes and in parts of the
world like very specific instructions
like you're the special family because
you have the witch doctor so you have to
abide by these specific criteria which
is very fascinating yeah not not that I
know of but um okay uh they so her grand
the whole family converted to
Catholicism okay actually so uh yeah at
some point in her childhood they all
converted to
Catholicism and so um but you know
because that pact was never broken uh
you know they the demons would come
after successive
Generations wow what we call
generational sins right right so so your
wife is dealing with this as a kid and
then does she know it's like bad like is
she is at this point is she even like
aware of God and Satan and all these
yeah she grew up as a Catholic okay um
but you know just for her it was normal
and the cousins would talk about it uh
amongst themselves that what they saw um
you know they would wake up uh you know
in in the middle of the night and see
demons right in front of their face uh
it was all quite normal for them and it
wasn't wasn't a big deal um maybe they
were scared at some point but uh you
know it was it was it was a normal
occurrence for them and and it wasn't a
big deal you know it's they it didn't
communicate there was no communication
but she could just see them so they
weren't interacting necessarily in her
own life or you know were they trying to
scare her or anything okay so they're
just just you know we're here hanging
out wow I'm glad I don't see those
things yeah that would be weird I mean
honestly you know what I mean I I I like
sleeping at nighttime
seriously yeah yeah so all of this
um uh I I didn't know about this when we
first got married oh and yeah yeah yeah
where it it by the way there's some
extra people at our wedding here you
know but it came to light um a couple of
years after we got married we I decided
to take a sabatical and uh I left my
business and we came over to the US
actually to a Bible school and uh we
were both studying she was studying
health I was studying Bible and uh when
we first got to uh Virginia for the
first 3 months as we were driving by the
side of the road at night she would
suddenly point out I see them at the
side of the road oh wow they're you know
in dark robes and holding a sickle uh or
she would see other forms uh of them and
she would point it out and we just
prayed really hard those first three
months and uh they disappeared after a
while and so that was kind of the first
time I knew that she saw things U but
then after that 3 months we never talked
about it again until 2019
okay and that was kind of the pivotal
Point uh for us in in 2019 how long had
you been married at this time um we got
married in 2005 at the end of 2005 we
went to came to the US in 2007 mhm um so
this was you know a good 12 years later
okay so 12 years into it and all of a
sudden what triggered this new kind of
experience so my son had been born in
2017 mhm and uh after he was born my
wife started to just slowly deteriorate
my wife's a very extroverted person uh
and she likes to go out and and be out
there and socialize meet with people
she's a very people person um but from
2017 onwards she started to spend more
time at home in the room just not
wanting to go out um at first you know
uh you know in in the first year I just
let her be because you know she needed
time to recover and I just assume it was
a second um birth uh for us and so um
you know she was just recovering from
that so uh I I didn't think much of it
um but then in 2018 things kind of got
worse uh and then you know in early
2019 um she started to hear things and
uh the things that she had seen before
and now started to speak to her uh and
for the first time she noticed that she
was going up the lift we live in a
condominium and as she was going up to
the lift uh there was somebody standing
next to her she was having a
conversation with him and then after she
got out of the lift uh my daughter who
was with her asked her mommy who are you
talking to oh wow and so she started to
notice and this is around March of 2019
oh wow something's not right um you know
I'm starting they're starting to
communicate with me and it's never
happened before now what is your first
reaction like oh no my wife needs like I
don't know help I mean I I don't know if
my wife has seen people that are not
there you know it's so she didn't tell
me okay so she kept this to herself for
about 3 months so from March till June
um she just kept this to herself and she
knew something was not right um but she
didn't want to you know get me worried
allow me and so she just kept this to
herself until we were on a holiday in
June um 2019 and and uh you know as as
we were as we put the kids to bed uh and
we were just talking outside um The
Villa where we were or on the beach she
told me David I think I've got
depression uh and I think you know I'm
psychos uh and so she started to tell me
what had happened and uh I didn't know
what to do never dealt with u mental
illness never dealt with de demons at
all uh in fact I would go out of my way
to avoid being involved you know there
were other pasted who had mentioned
things in uh Malaysia and and we had
cases before but you know I just I I
felt like the pastas could handle this
so I didn't want to touch this until
2019 when uh you know it uh my wife was
dealing with it so in the church you're
in the church at this point yes um is
this kind of something that's common
like you hear people like that are sort
of dealing with spiritual warfare like
this in Malaysia yes so so it's kind of
not as shocking of like a random
occurrence you know what I mean it's
just okay
there's with this yeah but shocking in
the in the sense that I never thought I
would have to deal with it right right
right yeah and so up until that point
I'd really try to avoid having to touch
any of this yeah so what was your first
mode of action like what were you what
were you what' you
do I just I spoke to my brother about it
you know we prayed um you know and I
prayed for my wife and uh but you know
she went she had an idea of what she
wanted to do already so when she came
back the way she dealt with it with it
was to go and see a
psychiatrist and so as soon as she spoke
to the psychiatrist described what was
going on um the psychiatrist told
diagnosed her as severe psychotic
depression okay and that can manifest
things so he was almost kind of coming
at the angle that this is not real your
mind is making this up yeah yeah
definitely wow definitely and he went
through all did he know about her
past uh well she shared as you know as
as they sat down to talk about it uh you
know through the counseling was this
individual a believer in God no okay
yeah so they put her on really heavy
medication mhm um she was taking Xanax
she was taking uh
anti-depressants and she was taking uh
sleeping pills uh and overnight she
literally became like a a zombie wow uh
you know it's um this medication
is it doesn't cure you all it does is
desensitize you to the things that
you're seeing and the voices that you're
hearing uh and so so you're still
continuing to kind of see or hear that's
right yeah but you just don't react to
it because it's literally blocking
freezing your brain blocking your
frontal lobe yeah um you know as Dr Neil
nedley or or his team will tell you uh
of this medication is is really bad for
you even if you don't believe in the
spiritual warfare side you really should
try to find natural remedies that uh can
replace all of this medication but at
that time we didn't know what to do so
she started going for this counseling
and uh for the next 3 months from June
to well to August um yeah all the way to
August she's taking all of this
medication and slowly deteriorating even
more and just hiding in the room all of
the time now she's not coming out and
she's just basically spending most of
her day in in the room in the depressed
and depressed in the dark yeah which is
alarming as a as a husband I mean you're
you know yeah what do you do you feel
helpless that's right how do I help you
you know yeah it's probably really
frustrating because you go you try to
get help and it doesn't fix a situation
she's still seen the stuff which is why
she was probably depressed in the first
place yeah if it's still there
presumably the depression wouldn't leave
that's right yeah so it was um
distressing uh and I didn't know and I
I'll have to admit U I was probably not
the most helpful and and the most
supportive at that time I I didn't know
how to deal with it um and
so um fast forward to August uh my
family comes to visit and uh it was at
that time we had our youth conference as
well so we were having aoi mhm and uh
normally when we have aoi it was in qual
lumper that year um just as when you
came and we stayed right in the city and
uh she came along with us but for the
whole time she's in the bedroom and uh
just staying in the darkness while we go
for the meetings the one or two times
that she did make it into the meeting
Hall uh as we started to sing even
before the sermon started she would just
hear screeching in her ears W and uh it
was unbearable for her so she had to run
out of the room and run back uh you know
run out of the the hall and run back to
the room uh and hide there again wow sad
did and she told you about this at the
meetings that's right yeah which you
you're very instrumental in in um sort
of helping orchestrate these meetings
together so I can imagine only what kind
of layer of stress that adds on to you
as you're here trying to minister to
others and you know your own spouse is
that's right yeah it was it was tough um
yeah that was that was really the
toughest year of my life Wow uh so right
after
aoi uh we come home and uh as a family
we had planned a family trip as a
holiday and my wife didn't want to go
she said I'm having too much
anxiety I can't go on the trip and I
said you know I don't want to leave you
home uh so I was trying to persuade her
to come and this snowballed into an
argument and then she ran into the room
and uh uh this is the first time I start
to think you know this is more than just
a medical or a physical thing or a
mental illness and so she runs into the
room and she looks up the ceiling and
she goes they're coming for me they're
coming for me and she starts to bite her
arm really hard her own arm her own arm
like this you know and she's biting her
own arm really hard I pull her hand away
from her mouth and then she pushes me
away and she runs for the window so in
our room we have um Florida ceiling
Windows um all the way and she runs out
the window and she bounces off the
window I go to grab her I pull her to
the
bed I ask my daughter to call my mother
who's here with us and she comes into
the room and we start to pray for her um
she's laughing this unnatural laugh
while we're praying but after a while of
praying and claiming Bible text she Cals
down uh and then when she calms down my
mom goes back to the room I put the kids
to bed I come back in the room it's all
dark she's sitting on the uh on one side
of the bed I'm on the other side of the
bed and she goes to me go and close the
window and I said the window's not open
we never open it and she said they told
me that it's open so I go over to the
window I draw the curtains aside and the
window is wide open and I have to
stretch my hand out all the way to close
the window so now as I reflect on it the
demons were trying to get her to jump
out the window and they had opened it
but the angel of the Lord I believe was
standing there and she bounced off the
angel of the Lord so amen um you know
all through this experience I could just
see how the Lord was protecting us and
uh you know keeping her safe so that
really shook me and uh I started to
think you know something does not feel
right here yeah I gotta I got to find
out how to fix this I me that's you go
into that mode right as man it's like
how do I fix
it so what do you do
well you know I I was just dazed I guess
for for a day or two um we finally went
off for the holiday she went with you
she she agreed to come and but the whole
time she's spending in the room still
and she's still taking this heavy
medication uh heavy heavily medic
dedicated uh and so you know the the the
family holiday wasn't really all that
fun uh we came back from the holiday my
parents and my sister and her family
they fly out and uh about a week later I
I'm you know driving back from work my
sister calls and she
says are you with Beverly my wife and I
said no I'm not with her I'm on the way
back from work she says you might want
to pull over to the side of the road so
we can talk so I pull over the side of
the road and uh she says to me I when I
got back the weekend we had a church
board meeting I was just sharing what
had happened with my church board member
and she said that is not uh severe
psychotic depression what your wife is
experiencing um that sounds like demonic
possession or harassment of some sort or
oppression and my sister asked her how
do you know and she says well
I've uh experienced this um you know
when I was younger my father suddenly
passed away and this is in Australia she
a fairly elderly lady in Australia she
she said my my father passed away and uh
one night um I heard him screaming I
woke up and the demons came to me and
asked me if I would like to see my
father and I said yes so over many many
days and weeks every night they would
bring him to see me uh and and I was
really glad for that and they started to
command me and ask me to serve them she
went into witchcraft astrology um you
know fortune telling uh and this
continued until the demons asked her to
kill her
family and she refused and she ran away
she ignored them for many decades they
were still there just like for my wife
um she never had a Deliverance never
cast them out but they were just there
but she just learned to ignore them kind
of in that movie Beautiful Minds right
wow yeah so uh you know she uh so she
starts to speak to my wife uh starts to
speak to my my sister and my sister
calls me and says she's willing to do
counseling with your wife uh and I said
well I don't know if she's going to be
willing or in in a good shape to be able
to speak to her so I prayed about it we
went home I spoke to my wife and uh
praise the Lord she was willing to speak
to her uh and so they started you know
counseling over the phone wow the first
time they do counseling um the lights
are flickering on and off in her house
at this lady's house and uh she realizes
yeah yeah this is what we're dealing
with yeah well she knew yeah yeah she
knew and uh so they were still
continuing to harass the elderly woman
man yeah so so they were flickering the
lights on and off and she had to tell my
wife just hold on for a sec and she
prayed uh and then the lights stopped
flickering on and off and then she came
back and started to speak to my wife
yeah and so she starts counseling
sessions with my wife they go for a few
sessions mhm and then my wife stopped
speaking to her and you know then I I
asked my wife what what's going on why
why did you stop speaking to her and she
said the demons told me that she's
spreading rumors about me she's telling
you know all sorts of um lies about me
um to the rest of the church to your
family and uh I don't want to speak to
her they're just little Liars aren't
they I mean that's that's what they're
good at right they just want to confuse
you and make you mad at everyone else
that's right they just have to get in
the middle of your relationships that's
right and and you know so that this
experience really helped me to
understand as soon as you start to
counsel with somebody or even as soon as
you start to witness to somebody even
who is not possessed this is the war
that's going on right that you don't
know what they're hearing on you know
they close the doors and you know
somebody's telling them like oh yeah
they're just here to like scope out your
place and steal from you you know who
knows but they're just liars that's
right wow yeah so for you know in this
case it was kind of obvious that you
know she was speaking to somebody else
uh but many times for all of us you know
so my first step in actually Counseling
in spiritual warfare is to understand
that not all of your thoughts are your
thoughts right is a very important thing
for counseling in spiritual warfare to
help somebody to understand that that
the devil can insert thoughts into our
minds MH um and they do it at a greater
scale for somebody who's possessed um to
the point that those thoughts will kind
of um possess you know take control of
them now now this is something that I
remember when when I had this
conversation with you in Malaysia like
that I guess I'd never really thought
about about it like that before and you
had brought up the point that they often
will speak in first person that's right
so like you think or you hear like you
know okay the story of this demon that's
oppressing me and he's sitting there
going you are depressed and it's like no
he's not saying you are depressed he
says I am depressed that's right so that
you over time begin to think that you're
the one that's thinking those thoughts
but those aren't even your thoughts
that's right that's that's what was
crazy I think a realization to me
because I mean I've I mean so who hasn't
been depressed right and and you just
wonder like yeah they're they're Demons
of these various different things and
they just sit there and they just tell
you I'm I'm suicidal I'm I'm I'm
depressed I'm this I'm that that's right
I'm hopeless I should myself I hate that
person you know um and as you
internalize these thoughts as you accept
these thoughts as your identity um it
takes over your emotions it takes over
your decision- making uh and that's how
they over decades uh and Sabrina will
share about some of the other people
that we've helped since then uh you know
that's how they take control of your
mind and uh um you be able to take your
identity yeah it's like if you give to
him enough I know we did this show with
um Chris Lang it was called um beware of
Angels or he had created a documentary
about um beware of angels and you guys
seen that no I not it's very interesting
um Bible study group and they wanted to
see angels and so they started asking
for manifestations and these angels
would show up and over time they
actually tried to convince or no didn't
try they they were doing Bible studies
they were doing Bible studies with the
angels like it took years but they
convinced them to kill everybody in the
Bible study and they did WOW shot them
all oh W and and um it was this it was
this crazy thing I mean and and these
guys were like conservative I mean they
weren't like they're going to a Bible
study they're wanting to know about God
they're not like wanting to like do
something evil but they gave into it
enough time so to hear you guys talk
about that you know from from that
elderly woman that experienced that sort
of thing basically trying to get her to
cause harm to someone else I mean that's
what they'll do they'll take control of
you and then force you to do something
bad that's right y that's that's
definitely their intention
so now we're at a situation where once
again I'm at a loss I don't know what to
do um I start to pray and continue to
pray and ask God you know please send
somebody to help my wife I continue to
search and speak to different Ministries
to see who who does this who does this
you know who who helps uh you know in
the area of spiritual warfare and I just
couldn't find anybody uh so now we're
coming into
September and um we're having our church
camp in the middle of September I think
it's around September 16th
and the church board is meeting normally
in our church camps we have our own
people speak we have young people speak
or you know people nearby but this year
one of our young people he comes to us
and he says can we invite this guy he's
in Korea right now he could you know
redirect his route through Malaysia to
come and speak at our camp and everyone
ask well what's he going to speak about
and and then he says depression and my
ears Pock up you know and uh I I'm
suddenly very interested in this and uh
he's a doctor that works together with
Neil dley at his uh depression Recovery
Center you know in Weimar and uh you
know I I everyone's like depression who
speaks about depression at a at a camp
you know at a church camp right so
everyone was not really in favor but
after the meeting I spoke to my my
brother and I said hey you know can can
you speak to everybody else personally
and ask if they can uh approve for the
speaker to come because you know and he
was the only one who knew what was
happening in our family uh we were
trying to hide all of this and and just
didn't want anybody else to know about
it so he spoke to everybody and uh you
know the doctor came his name is Dr
Eddie Ramirez he came into the camp and
just uh before the camp he stayed a
couple of days with us and in those
couple of days he counsel with my wife
and helped her to understand the
negative uh the terrible effects of the
medicine that she was taking helped us
to understand and uh came up with a plan
for her to get off that to something
that was more natural um so Xanax is
really bad for the brain it it blocks
the frontal lobe literally blocks us
from being able to communicate with God
from being able to feel conviction from
God you know and and put um thoughts
together to reason from the word you
know if you if you try to take Xanax and
you try to read the Bible nothing is
going sense yeah it doesn't make sense
yeah so you know she we she was really
glad for that uh Council you know and
and I praise the Lord for bringing Dr
Eddie at that time then we go to the cam
and she tries to go cold turkey which is
not advisable
uh and so she goes cold turkey and stops
taking the medicine for that whole C wow
and she's really joyful she's really
happy and then we get to the end of the
camp and it's the last night and the
speaker is getting up to speak and as he
starts to speak my wife starts to draw
and I'm sitting right next to her and
she's drawing all these dark figures oh
and I'm asking her what what's going on
why are you drawing you know what are
you seeing and she's like as everyone's
coming into the room I demons are
starting to come in and they're filling
this whole room and they're surrounding
us and she starts to panic and she
starts to get more and more nervous and
then uh just as a speaker is about to
get they're they're doing they're
singing and just as a speaker is about
to get up she says to me go and get the
medicine I need the medicine and so I
run out I grab the medicine uh my
brother's there with his wife and
they're praying with her and uh when I
come back with the medicine we continue
to pray she takes the medicine and so in
her mind you know she's thinking the
medicine's going to help me in our minds
the prayer is helping her um but what I
realized from that experience is that
the demons really want us to stay on
that medicine yeah they want you
intoxicated yeah they need you
intoxicated for whatever reason so is
Eddie the speaker that night uh he was
not it was one of our young people there
another person yeah so it was one of our
young people who was he did he advise so
he didn't advise her to go cold turkey
was he trying to get her to wean off
like slowly yeah yeah he was yeah but in
her I guess excitement she decided to
you know I'm just going to stop this now
having said that she'd only been taking
it for a few months so it's not as bad
as somebody taking for years or decades
uh you definitely have to be careful
about weaning of that but there are
definitely natural remedies um you know
which Dr Neil nedley and Dr Eddie have
researched uh as replace replacements
for this which are uh not harmful so how
did that night play out so she calmed
down uh finally after after about
probably half an hour of praying uh and
also when the medicine started to take
effect and uh and then we left Camp uh
and then in the next week um we reached
out to Weimar um because Dr Eddie had
encouraged us to uh speak to them and uh
he gave us a number for um uh Dr Neil
nedley's assistance we reached out to
them uh but before they accept you in
the program they run through a series of
questions uh and one of those questions
is do you see things do you hear things
and of course my wife said yes to that
uh unfortunately at the end of that um
interview they said we can't help you
you know our program really only deals
with simple depression MH uh and not you
know s psychotic depression so now
you're left with no option yeah so at
the end of that call after we hung up my
wife bursts into tears and you know she
was in Despair and she was saying
nobody's going to be able to help help
me nobody can help me and uh it was
really at that moment and and I really
that moment has stuck in my mind uh all
of these years that I made the decision
to the Lord that if he would help my
wife to get well I would uh spend the
rest of my life trying to get back at
Satan by helping anybody he would bring
to me uh with spiritual warfare you know
and and uh I love it I committed my my
my heart to this ministry and and being
able to help others in this position
because I I felt the hopelessness the
helplessness of that when you can't when
you feel like you're under bondage to
the enemy and you just can't you can't
uh have Victory I think that's my exact
response that I would have i' I've I've
had this conversation and and been like
look devil if you're going to cause this
thing then I'm going to flip it around
on your head and I'm going to go in
Souls with that thing so the more you
pile on the more souls I'm going to take
you know like yeah it's a good good good
that from there also that you know if
God Wills if he opens the door for us um
that we would start a depression
Recovery Center in Malaysia uh to really
not only look at simple depression but
to help those with um psychosis
schizophrenia bipolar spiritual warfare
and uh yeah spiritual warfare and the
years since that we have dealt with a
lot of these kinds of cases wow so how
did you begin to even know where to
start like you're looking around on the
internet like what do I do about this
yeah well it was really just praying cuz
I was at a loss I spoke to the Lifestyle
Center in Malaysia I spoke to Weimar now
I tried to reach out to um you know
lifestyle centers in in Indonesia or in
Korea and and all of them came back and
said sorry we we we don't deal with
these kind of cases because it takes up
too much of our time or you know we're
just not equipped for that and I
realized that this is a real Gap
this is a real Gap in the church that we
somehow as a church have forgotten that
demons do exist yeah uh We've forgotten
as a church that um you know Christ
commanded us as part of the Gospel
commission to heal to teach to preach to
disciple and to cast out demons you see
that as an intimate part of the work
that the early Apostolic church was
doing that's right I mean you see it all
the time back then right why would we
not think that we're any different and
if we are going to return to A Primitive
godliness right or some sort of form of
this Apostolic Church you know idea I'm
sure the Demonic world is getting
stronger and stronger we may deal with
that even more so than they did back
then yes you don't hear people talking
about this no we don't not enough so I
was searching everywhere um and uh uh in
the process I well firstly I called out
to Dr Eddie and I said hey Dr Eddie um
we didn't except my wife what's going on
and he's like I'm really sorry about
that but you know there is somebody that
you could talk to when we do case when
we do get cases like this that we feel
like it's beyond our capability to be
able to handle we do get um you know
somebody else involved and his name is
Paul KF and so I reached out to uh Paul
KF he is a counselor uh a Christian
counselor uh and he uh I reached out to
him and he started now to come into the
picture and and he starts to speak to my
wife and my wife agrees to have
counseling sessions with him over the
phone uh and they start to speak uh in
counsel and he was instrumental in
helping my wife to start to to restart
her devotional life to see the
importance of the word of God in
weakening their hold over her and also
in how to pray how to pray not
superficial prayers but to claim the
word of God as a sword to fight back um
we're still trying to figure this whole
thing out um we thought we had some
light because of Dr Eddie coming then
that door kind of closed shut and then
now we're looking for somebody else and
the Lord just brings somebody else uh
into the picture and and as I reflect on
it I just realized you know through that
year it just felt like a decade um you
know maybe a century but uh you know the
Lord was slowly bringing different
people into my wife's life into our
lives um to show us the steps of what we
needed to do um to to break their hold
over my wife so Paul kind of starts to
counsel with my wife and the first time
he he speaks to her um the demons are
there uh they're they start to open the
doors close the doors move furniture um
they start to um grab her hand and and
freeze her whole whole arm that's
holding the the phone to talk to him uh
and they start to you know give her
bruises and and hurt her uh and so
they're really trying to intimidate
disturb intimidate her and and to
disturb uh you know and and break up
this this meeting uh and and rightfully
so because Paul KF was starting to share
the weapons of warfare with my wife and
slowly weaken their hold as she starts
to read the word of God and she starts
to learn how to pray in a way uh by
claiming Bible texts that will use it as
a happen against them right so for many
of us we pray but we don't quote
scripture in our prayer and and it's
such a important aspect or or such a
powerful weapon when we're fighting
against the enemy you talked about um
the Psalms being spiritual warfare lots
of lots of spiritual warfare in the
Psalms yes and and actually I'm I'm I'm
kind of digesting the Psalms again um um
recently in my own de devotional study
life and and I have this thought in my
mind and it po up you know and I go wow
wow you're right I mean right there
there's a lot of arrows of of of warfare
right there that's right that's right
yeah is there anything happening on
Paul's end like what's happening to your
wife because with the original lady yes
the one from that had lived in Australia
or fro from Australia there were things
going on on her end while she's
communicating but is there anything
happening with him I'm not sure he
didn't mention uh to to us on that is
this something he's dealt with is that
why he got into it yeah he's dealt with
that yeah so he he deals with a lot of
counseling and especially a lot of uh
people with abuse and he's written a
really great book called The Hidden half
of the Gospel uh in the hidden half of
the Gospel he explores how Jesus was
abused how Jesus was born in a broken
family how Jesus was um you know
violated at the cross uh and violated by
his own people so he helps those who are
abused to relate right back to the
savior because many of them feel like
well Jesus is perfect m and uh how could
I believe in somebody who is perfect uh
and and never experienced what I
experienced so he really helps to open
up the eyes of those who have dealt with
abuse to see that Jesus went through
everything you went through maybe not
exactly um but he understood abuse I
know yeah Jesus uh um I've read in um
there's a there's a there's a really
great book that uh actually talked about
his depression and to me that spoke to
me just going wow I just never really
thought of Jesus being depressed before
so is Paul kind of the last stop on this
train or is there other people along the
way he's not yeah so um after a few
culation sessions yet again the demons
get involved and they uh are putting
things in my wife's mind and she stops
talking to him as well and I'm in
despair again um it was a difficult
month
after from September to October um you
know there were times where they would
wake her up in the middle of of the
night and Comm compulse her to go to the
kitchen to grab a
knife were you in on these sessions that
she was having with him no no so do did
she share the contents of what he was
sharing yeah okay he had a workbook
okaying some of what's going on yeah
yeah so he was guiding me he would send
me the workbooks I would print it out he
would go through with her you know but
the basis of it all the the foundation
of it all was prayer Bible study and
learning to talk to God and learning how
to use the word as a sword mhm um to
fight the demons yeah so that was that
was the foundation but this all stopped
and um and then we had this period of
time where the demons were really um
fighting hard to take control and push
her over the edge so if they're telling
her to go to the kitchen and grab a
knife and come and are you now fearful
to sleep oh I was asleep at that time
but but but thankfully you know there's
the other than that uh you know when
when she by the time she related it to
me uh you know she was telling me but I
couldn't get up because the angel of the
Lord was holding you know something was
holding me down was what she said you
realize there's an amount of spiritual
warfare there that's protecting you in
the room as well that's right that's a
good that's a good point so that that
really helped me um to overcome any sort
of fears as I deal with demons to
realize that if I'm right with the Lord
if I've confessed my sins or if I'm just
you know walking with the Lord and I'm
not talking in a powerful way here but
as long as we're giving access to the
Lord into our lives he's protecting us
amen you know there's a lot of times
people tell me oh I'm really worried
about getting involved in Deliverance
because I'm worried that the demons are
going to jump into me and my response to
that is you shouldn't worry about that
because if the demon could jump into you
they would have jumped into you you
don't have to a demon possessed person
for the devil to jump into you that's
called Hollywood movies exactly did you
start claim well after that point maybe
when you found out were you did your
prayer life change a little bit at all
or did you start claiming Promises of
protection and be like definitely you
know no weon formed against me shall
prosper definitely and and it was in
those times um that scripture songs
became so precious to me uh not just to
me every morning my daughter who's 6
years old at that time uh 6 seven years
old at that time you know we would get
up and we would sing scripture songs and
we would just claim those texts and pray
uh for my wife you know and just your
children are fully aware of the
situation that's my daughter was yeah
yeah my daughter was you you can't hide
that in the home unfortunately beautiful
I mean to me that that that should be
worth Legions of good Angels right a
child getting up and singing script
songs it's like no Demon's going to be
able to overtake that come on God is God
is always protecting of of of of
children but you know I think that
children are a powerful weapon in this
situation as well yeah I mean I
recognize in that time her prayers were
more powerful than mine because it came
from an innocent and Pure Heart yeah oh
man so so we were just in that time you
know the Lord was so close to us through
the scripture and and I really
understood the power of God's word you
don't understand the power of God's word
until you have to use it to defend
yourself and and to fight the enemy and
unfortunately I think many of us don't
use it that's right I think we go that
sounds nice yeah we wrote that on the
wall you know that makes a great t-shirt
right but we don't use it in that
situation yeah and and I think that that
we need to get more bolstered up with
like what kinds of scriptures you know
deal with what I we should know that
right off the top of my head if I'm
dealing with this what do I use if I'm
dealing with this what do I use you know
like that's right these are these are a
tool belt right yes yes oh well it's
it's our armor yeah it's it's our Shield
it's our weapon so yeah Christians
really underestimate the power of God's
word yeah right until you deal with
situations like this yeah um so you know
coming back to your question Keith what
what happened next uh we continue to
pray and I was at a loss you know and
and with these situations um that were
happening you know with with my wife and
and there were times where she was awake
and she also went and grabbed a knife
and and and ran you know they compuls
her and and they took over but every
time she did Angel of the Lord would
stand in front of us and she couldn't
you know she couldn't move forward any
further uh and so we were dealing with
these situations and it just felt like
it was really heavy in the home we
continue to pray and one day and I at
the same time I was praying to the Lord
asking him Lord I know I need to help my
wife but I still need to work we need to
support ourselves so what do I do how
long do I take off I'd like to help I'd
like to take some time off to spend
extended amount of time in prayer and
also just trying to search more to see
where in the world I can bring my wife
and so that was my prayer Lord please
show me how long I need to take off uh
and all of this kind of came to head one
day I was traveling for work I was in
Indonesia and again my sister uh calls
me up and she says you know David I
found somebody else who can help us now
and I said oh great who's this and she
said um it's a lady she works in a
Lifestyle Center in Australia outside of
uh Melbourne and uh she deals with
demonic uh and uh you know and she she
deals with demons she casts them out and
I said great this is you know what I've
been uh praying for looking for her and
she said uh I've organized for her to
speak to you tomorrow morning um so the
next morning I wake up early in the
morning and uh turn on the shower get
ready and close the door of the shower
and just brush my teeth doing a whole
bunch of things to get ready I run to
the shower but somehow even though the
shower door was shut the whole bathroom
has been flooded with water and as I'm
running my legs fly up in the air I land
on the side of my um on on my side and I
break my ribs oh and I black out oh wow
and as soon as I wake up just because of
all the thoughts of spiritual warfare
that's always been these last few months
I just all I could say in my mind was
help me gone yeah cuz I can breathe you
know when you break your ribs itur you
can't breathe for for a short amount of
time and uh and I was just praying and
for about 10 seconds I couldn't really
breathe at all uh and as I uted up that
prayer breath came in m and I got up
painfully went into the shower showered
came out got dressed called this lady I
was a little bit late and I apologized
and she said oh once I explained to her
what had happened I she said you know
normally when I'm about to have a
conversation about this it's quite
normal for these things to happen sorry
I should have warned you oh wow so we go
into the discussion I tell her what's
been happening and uh after I describe
everything she said yep uh sounds like
your wife is
possessed um you know
or almost there or or harassed yeah yeah
so she said look I I I don't know for
sure and the only way I can really help
her is if you bring her here to
Australia for me to counsel with her and
this is the last session of the year so
you got to come in two weeks time
otherwise um oh wow I'm traveling and
the only time I can deal with this is
maybe February next year so there's a
sense of urgency there uh we've wrap up
our call I actually end up going to some
meetings come back and I fly back to
Malaysia now it's still painful at my
side here and by the weekend I couldn't
get up to go to
church and by the end of Sabbath uh when
everyone came home and some of the Bible
workers had come over uh they brought me
to the hospital and I'm doing an x-ray
and MRI and they find out that I'm
having appendicitis and at the same time
I've broken two ribs
oh wow so they give me 2 months off as
an MC wow uh you know and uh as as
medical leave yeah so now God has
answered my prayer yeah I've got two
months to deal with the
situation and uh wow um when I get out
of the
hospital um I speak to my wife and say
hey we got to go to Australia there's
this lady who can help you and she says
no oh wow of course yeah not going to be
easy but I have two weeks off
two months two months two months yeah so
I had two months off and uh I just I
prayed I tried my best to negotiate uh
you know as charmingly as I could but
the answer was no because every time she
thought about it they put anxiety in her
heart really heavy anxiety and she said
I'm going to die if I get on that plane
now by this time the demons had been
telling her every single moment of the
day by the end of this year either
you're going to kill your husband and
live
or I'm going to we're going to kill you
so you have to make a decision so she's
starting to prepare to die cuz she's not
going to kill me right uh and she can't
bring herself to kill me though there's
times they have tried to kill me wow um
but uh she's preparing to die by the end
of the year uh and and that's weighing
heavy on her mind so she's not going to
get on a plane and make it easy for them
to bring the plane down in her mind so
she refuses to go and again we're in
despair and I had to tell the lady we're
not coming I'm sorry um so my my
daughter and I we continue to pray pray
pray a couple of weeks later we so now
we're coming into end of October now um
I get a call from my sister again and
she says the first lady who she spoke to
her church board member um just called
her and told her she's coming to
Malaysia and my sister's like what are
you going to do in Malaysia say I don't
know but the Lord impressed my heart
that I have to fly to Malaysia to help
David's
wife and I'm like great so um do they
know what to do and uh my sister says
nope they have no idea what to do my mom
is going to come along with her because
she's never been to Malaysia so MH my
mom agreed to come along with her so
these two elderly ladies have been
impressed they have to fly to Malaysia
to help my wife so the Lord put in my
mind at that point well before they
please go and see the lady who's working
at the Lifestyle Center because she
knows what to do so they go and see her
the weekend before they fly out and
she's teaching them Theory and uh you
know what what they should be doing and
at the end of it just before they leave
she says to them well I think the best
thing I can do for you is to show you
how I would normally do a Deliverance
nothing happens uh you know if you don't
have any demons nothing's going to
happen so don't worry about it we're
just going to go through this as a
process so that you see how it's done so
they go through a Deliverance for the
lady in the church board and they end up
casting out a bunch of demons because
they've been there since she accepted
their invitation to see her dad oh wow
right so they've been with her all of
this time even though she got baptized
yeah um you know came back to the church
uh but they're still there yeah so they
managed to cast out a whole bunch of
demons uh there was a demon there that
had been trying to a demon of
uh for the last year she'd had something
like over 10 accidents car accidents oh
wow and so they were trying to take her
life Wow uh and they they cast him out
the next day when they got home my
sister and uh the church board member
they want to practice on my mom before
they fly and they ended up casting out
even more demons from her because my
wife uh my mom is a first
generation um Christian m mhm and
uh before she got baptized she was a
Buddhist and she used to worship her
ancestors when she was about 13 14 uh
she got bullied at school she came home
and for many weeks she was praying to
her ancestors asking them for help
against the bullies so the demons had
come into her at that point and even
baptism was not enough to expel them wow
and they'd been there
for most of her life and and you know
from my all of my memory of childhood
all I remember is my mom having this
Unholy temper interesting little things
would just set her off for no reason it
would just be normal things but she just
you eating some spicy
[Laughter]
food that's right yeah so you know here
after this Deliverance she's just super
calm it like my my sister told me it's
like the demoniacs of garine you know
I'm looking at Mom and she just has this
peace peace this calmness about her that
you can't explain which we never she'd
never seen before in my mom and so
through this
experience you know as I look back why
did God kind of extend this out because
he needed to bring Deliverance to both
um this lady and also my mom uh and so
they are delivered and they're on fire
and then now flying over to Malaysia uh
on Monday
and as soon as they come uh we decide to
go out to the Lifestyle Center in
Malaysia to get out of the city to kind
of get away from stuff uh you know the
city life and also do a bit of detox
before we try to do the Deliverance uh
not that you need to but you know we
just that was in our mind at the time so
we get away and um my mom and the ladies
start to counsel with my wife and I
together and uh you know my wife starts
to really p out her heart about
unforgiveness that she'd built up over
kind of the decade of her marriage um
through coming into the church and
feeling like you know she always had to
play catchup and so there was just a lot
of things I had built up but for my wife
you know unforgiveness was that open
door that allowed them to come in and
the way that she used to describe it to
me was um the demons had influenced her
to build a wall of unforgiveness so for
her her unforgiveness was a protection
it was a wall she was building it was
her castle MH um but what she didn't
realize was that she was keeping in the
demons in that castle interesting and it
was the open door to keep them the legal
right as we say to allow them to come
into her life uh and so you know as she
continued to Build That Wall of
unforgiveness so for her I guess her
habitual sin her weakness just as it is
for an alcoholic to drink or you know a
drug user to um you know to use drugs
for her her habit is to build up
unforgiveness wow and not let it go not
to you know reconcile that and and
that's that's a a habit for her that she
struggles with that really um makes me
think of that song There's a flag Flying
high in the castle of my heart right
yeah do we have these like flags of
things that we struggle with yeah and
it's like you place that flag there and
the Demon's like nope I'm I'm I'm
occupying this uh castle at this point
interesting so as we're
counseling uh the demons take over and
possess her and start to scream out at
us and saying you're not taking her uh
we're going to take her in a different
voice yeah different voices like you're
hearing like a man's voice or like a
yeah different different tones of voices
well actually for my mother her when
they were doing the Deliverance for her
uh one of the demons in there that took
over uh had a man's voice wow so
suddenly she had a man's voice wow yeah
but for my wife it was not that obvious
but different tones what she did mention
was that um when they first came to her
there were only three of them three
demons and as it got through the year uh
from March onwards it became five and
then by the time uh my mother and uh you
know this lady came it was nine demons
that were just surrounding her
everywhere so she could never sleep wow
wow yeah so at night they were just
constantly chattering into her her ears
and of course that's comes in you want
to just you want to go to sleep
exhausting yeah it was yeah so she just
said like it never switched off you know
her her mind uh the voices they were
just constantly going and going and
going and she just couldn't get any
sleep wow yeah so they take over um you
know she's possessed uh and uh at that
point you know the uh the ladi's
appealing to my wife to confess and just
say I forgive I forgive David you know
those were the words she was impressed
to tell her to say to me um and uh and
she's trying to speak but they're
they're strangling her they're holding
her neck so she can't get any words out
uh and she struggles like that for
probably a good 15 20 minutes and we're
praying for her uh she calms down when
she tries to speak again they'll
strangle her uh and uh you know finally
she says similar things to um that first
time I saw her possessed you know
they're coming for me they're coming for
me they say they're coming for me uh and
finally she got the words out I forgive
David as soon as she says that boom
they're gone peace peace wow and they
came and they left so I guess my
question in in thinking of that is you
look at the experience of like the
demoniac and this guy is he can't speak
for himself
essentially but God knows what's going
on in his heart and mind
so I guess I'm sitting here
thinking is it like critical that she
says that or do it just have to be a
conscious decision that she makes you
know in other words is it the verbal
confession that matters or is it the
change of heart and mind I think it's
different for everyone okay but in this
case it was important for her to say it
out uh and more often than not it's
important to verbalize um so one thing
we've learned as we have helped a lot of
other
people demons can't read our minds right
God can yes um but if you're to rebuke
them using the Bible you can't say it in
your mind you have to verbalize it you
have to verbalize it you know you have
to pray verbally as well so they have to
hear it because somehow the word of God
does something to to them mhm um as a
sword I like to think of it as you know
we're piercing them and it hurts and you
know when we're doing Deliverance for
others we do read Bible texts and uh
they hate that so when they put somebody
to unconscious or to sleep or paralyze
them uh the way to remove them is to
pierce them with the sword of truth uh
and so you read Bible texts what we like
to do is we read Bible texts uh about
Jesus the name of Jesus the power of
Jesus you know and what he's done for us
and as we keep reading that I visualize
that we're taking the sword and we're
piercing them and uh until such time
that they can't take the pain anymore
and they let go I can imagine that these
demons I mean we don't know how long
they lived with God before they decided
to fall with Lucifer but um um maybe
that brings their minds back to
reminding that they have fallen and they
can't stand it you know what I mean like
like I'm sure they they have some kind
of a memory of what their past was so if
you sing songs or you sing you know you
say Bible verses that are talking
literally about like you know Jesus is
like this right they remember the kind
you know Jesus in heaven they hate him
but they I'm I'm sure they just can't
stand it because it's a painful reminder
of what's a painful reminder to them and
and like you said I think that's that's
that's annoying enough to them to be
like I want to I want to leave I had
this I lost it I'd like to think it's
more than just an annoyance it's really
i' like to you know the Bible puts it as
the sword of truth yeah and so we really
are hurting them yeah uh somehow uh with
the sword and I remember yeah go sorry I
remember being in a deliverance and we
were casting him out we're claiming
bible promises after bible promises and
then the demon said put down your sword
and we were just keep claiming even more
and he they were like oh stop stop put
down your sword yeah so and all of this
is coming out of the person so their
voic is being used you're not hearing
some voice that's externally in the room
that that is not being used through the
mouth no they're speaking person just
that's still Eerie mhm wow it is yeah
especially for the student that came
right after 2019 um cuz yeah when we
were doing Deliverance uh the first
reaction they would just scream out loud
like this shrieking scream at you know
high volume and uh you know it would it
would freak out some of the Bible
workers I mean we learn to come to
expect it but uh the first couple of
times it was just you know quite uh
scary absolutely I've never seen
anything like this in my life and I
don't want to see it but but but I mean
like if I'm presented with the you know
know like what you experienced right
it's like you want to run from it but no
this is what we're called to do and this
is why we're having this conversation
and I think this is something that we
all need to sit down and really think
about and pray about and understand how
do we deal with this because you know if
your loved one or someone near you is
confronted with this who's going to help
them right now you told me about the I I
don't know how much you want to share
about the um the Bible worker but um you
told me about her and and and and it
leaving but also kind of like calling
sins out in the room right and so like
how do you prepare everybody to go into
that situation because you if is there
something that you can do that basically
they cannot mention your sins yeah you
just got to confess so confession so
before we go into a deliverance we will
all gather together and silently confess
our sins and it's become so meaningful
to me that literally when we confess our
sins he is faithful and just to forgive
us of our sins and cover us with his
righteousness immediately yeah just as
when the leper came to Jesus and he
asked for him to be cleansed yeah Jesus
spoke and immediately he was gone yeah
so that really has brought home to me
because there's been times where I've
confessed but I don't feel clean I don't
feel like I I'm worthy to go into a into
a battle with demons uh and and I'm
equipped you know and but that's just a
feeling but the reality is God has
covered us with the blood of Jesus and
we are perfect Amen in the sight of God
that's why I like hearing this it's like
the physical application to what we're
learning with the theory right no you
know it's like you go to school all this
time you guys are like not in school
literally you're in the School of Life
yes and now you're
applying this spiritual warfare that
we've been reading about and learning
about now you're seen it in in its front
line sure yeah wow can I just finish off
yeah the story for my wife yeah um so
just one last little bit right after
this Deliverance in the evening um she's
sitting at the bed and uh you know as as
we go to bed she tells me David there's
one last thing the Holy Spirit spoke to
me and told me that when we get home uh
we need to burn a rosary bead and this
was a rosary bead that had been given to
her by her mom when she came to look
after her in
2017 um there there was a month where
she looked after her as she recovered
after giving birth to our son and she
had given her a rosary be a rosary bead
and told her um remember once a Catholic
always a Catholic this is a special
rosary bead that's been blessed in the
Vatican and I want you to keep this so
she took it and she was like well I
don't believe in it but you know I'll
just put it aside um you know and uh
keep it in there and I believe as I
reflect on it now that was kind of the
beginning the you know one of the major
open doors to allow the demons to start
working in our home and really getting
us to the point of 2019 and so when we
get back I bring the rosary beads out I
burn it um and try to destroy it and as
I'm destroying it at that very moment
I'm outside I decide to leave the home
um the demons come back and speak to her
one last time she can't see them anymore
but they speak to her one last time and
told her your parents are going to be
very disappointed that you destroyed
this and then they're gone and she's
never had an issue with them
again we had once more um you know and
and I think once there is uh you know
you you once demons have come uh they
will always try to come back and there's
always that danger that's the story that
Jesus told right seven you know he went
and found the man swept his house and
that's right went and got seven more
unclean spirits yeah so so the danger
for my wife always is to make sure that
she uh gets rid of the wall of
unforgiveness uh and and so
reconciliation is very important in our
home um communion is very important for
us to clear you know our hearts out
between one another uh you know and she
has to guard her heart from
unforgiveness you know and I have to
make sure I do my part to give her the
opportunity to talk about that and and
clear it and you know forgive one
another uh and so they did come back
once more and devotion and devotion
Family Worship all of that are super
important for us as a family because uh
remember third and fourth generation so
my daughter is fourth
generation uh and so you know it's it's
even today it's it's always yet it's
always top most in my mind that uh
they're going to go after my daughter
they're going to find an angle to her as
well so um we constantly talk about that
and uh you know we I'm always on God I'm
always praying for for my family in that
respect wow couple things as we as we're
closing up here give me a short synopsis
of the what do you do give me this give
me the spiritual warfare plan if you
would right so just you know really
briefly uh counseling wise um when we
sit down to help somebody with uh
spiritual warfare and we've we've seen
people who are openly possessed people
are dealing with different types of
depression bipolar schizophrenia the
lady from Australia um you know has
continued to Mentor me and also Tim uh
you know after that I got connected with
Tim and you know we've been together on
some deliverances as well uh she told me
that there has not been a case of
bipolar schizophrenia that she hasn't
had to deal with demons wow so you know
that's that's always topmost in our mind
but three very important things to think
about when you're dealing with um
spiritual warfare number one your
thoughts demons attack us in our
thoughts that's where they start and so
your thoughts are not always your
thoughts and you have to learn to ask
God for wisdom to decipher uh what are
your thoughts and what are theirs
generally anything negative is coming
from the Devil the devil is not going to
leave it to our own strength and our own
uh immorality or you know insufficiency
to fall into sin he's going to do
everything he can to push us in that
direction so any negative thoughts in
your mind just remember that uh there's
a demon behind that and so there's a
demon of anger there's a demon of um
lust there's a demon of unforgiveness
there's a demon of Pride jealousy you
just label all of them as demons the
Bible tells us to guard our hearts and
guard our minds that's right yeah so um
you know so the first step your thoughts
are not your thoughts the Second Step
why is it that they can gain access to
our minds in more powerfully than others
uh because we have open doors powerful
open doors yeah I'm not wall of
forgiveness rosary be could be different
things that's right but there's a reason
why they're there that's right there's
three categories of open doors um which
I normally cover in in my training the
first one is generational sins so it
started right from when my wife was born
uh you know the demons lay claim to her
already because her grandmother had made
a pact with the devil so generally uh
the first category is gener generational
sins and once you find out about that
you just ask God to break those uh
secondly sins of the flesh sins of of
the flesh Pride unforgiveness lust Etc
all of those if we make that our
identity and we uh choose to be
identified as uh an angry person choose
to embrace unforgiveness choose to
embrace Pride Etc um that you know in a
powerful way then that opens the doors
for demons to come in most commonly we
have seen that usually it is
unforgiveness that's the biggest one
uh and typically unforgiveness for those
who have faced
abuse uh and so a lot of the times as
I'm counseling with somebody I'm think
I'm asking God to reveal what in their
childhood has caused this so when we
talk about unforgiveness it's not
somebody did something to you yesterday
you can't forgive them today it's more
like somebody did something to you 10
years ago 20 years ago 30 years ago and
you're still holding on to that
unforgiveness uh and that op opens the
door you know wide open for for demons
to come in WoW uh and then the third
category is
really occult stuff so anything from ult
books or movies movies
music um speaking in tongues fortune
telling yeah fortune telling paying
attention to the horoscopes mhm um WIA
boards um bracelets that have been
Charmed or Enchanted yeah um so you know
we don't realize that there are a lot of
things in this world that Satan has put
enchantments on they're not just simple
bracelets or they're not just simple
music right right God uh Satan has cast
a spell on those things and as we watch
them they're going to open a door so
there was a mother who brought her
children to me um her daughter was
herself uh and as we counseled um the
Holy Spirit led us to the fact that uh
they were watching horror movies uh and
they were like 10 11 years old oh wow
and I told the mother you have to get
rid of those movies get rid of the
television right and she's she said to
me what am I going to do to how my
children going to be entertained cuz I
have to work right and they're at home
and the only way is to let them watch TV
and I said well you're going to have to
make a choice you want your children
possessed or do you want them
entertained read books make a choice
read books yeah so learn something yeah
so so a cult is is much broader than we
think it's not just about witches or
Wizards you know it's um all sorts of
things that that touch stuff that you
bring into the home you might have gone
on a family trip and uh you know I
remember watching a testimony on LED
yeah about the Russian dolls right oh
yeah uh and and somebody mentioning that
and uh um I had to destroy that through
watching that my parents were mission
Aries when they first got married and
they went to Africa somehow they ended
up with a bunch of just African you know
faces and art and this and that and I
remember as a kid we had this Buddha and
it was um they had had it on a shelf and
it was just a bunch of stuff that they
had gotten on their on their trip and we
had a huge fish tank and we could not
keep fish alive and I I mean it was a
weird thing but I I wonder looking back
on it now is just like was all those
things influencing that I don't know
fish are hard to take care of in general
but right I I really do think that there
is reality to that yeah there's
definitely an influence in the home when
you bring Enchanted stuff uh into the
home um so open doors we got to discover
the open doors and they have to confess
it and ask God to break the stronghold
of the enemy uh and as so so a big part
of the counseling is just the Holy
Spirit leading us to what are the open
doors that you have opened in your life
um now you may confess them and close
doors but more often than not it's a
habitual sin so a lot of times you're
going to fall back into that so you know
it's going through uh and and doing this
repeatedly until God gives you that
final Victory uh as you continue to
confess as you continue to study the
Bible as you continue to use prayer uh
you know and and uh the word of God as a
weapon uh at some point uh the Lord says
enough uh you guys have to go so then
you find somebody that is possessed what
are the steps things that you can do you
guys have mentioned music scripture
songs Bible texts give us a couple of
those yeah so after we go through the
open doors the confession we just share
with them the simple tools of warfare uh
the weapons right and one of them so if
Satan gives us negative thoughts and
he's creating that identity how do I
counteract that I need to counteract
that with the thoughts of God and so we
need to learn to memorize scripture
easiest way scripture songs so uh you
know part of the mission of one of our
Ministries music verse is to keep
composing scripture songs and to put it
in a place where we can give to people
who are struggling with uh spiritual
warfare so you know before I came I just
counseled with somebody who is dealing
with that uh and she's um you know she's
not Christian um but I told her look
this is going to help you download music
verse hear the list of songs listen to
those songs memorize them sing them all
the time and it will start to weaken the
devil's hold on you I was really
surprised my B my wife had introduced me
to a book cuz she was interested in the
whole um nedley program that you
mentioned and one of those books that
they recommend is called telling
yourself the truth I don't know if
you're familiar with that book or had
read that book but it's it's pretty
fascinating it's uh written by a
Christian Author and he walks through
and just andares and he shows like look
we tell ourselves a lot of lies right
I'm not good enough no nobody likes me
you know this person's always mad at me
whatever yeah and his method is is like
you're saying learning to
recognize those are not from God that's
right and then using scripture to
replace those thoughts that's right so
it's pretty powerful and when you when
you go through that you realize oh wow
there's a lot of thoughts that are not
you know that not from God that's right
and and so you you want to dispel those
as much as possible so it's it's a
fascinating it's fascinating read yeah
so as we study the Bible it's
reprogramming our minds with a new
identity uh you know for those who have
been possessed um or dealt with uh
different types of mental illness for
the longest time they have given too
much credibility to the Demonic thoughts
that they put in our minds um but other
than that we need to clean house so we
need to look at the things in our lives
that we need to get rid of the music um
you know that we're listening to the
movies that we need to get rid of these
are all open doors so we need to start
to clean our home and our laptops and
our phones and all of that and we need
to get rid of any avenues that allowing
them to come in um you know we have uh
one of our Bible workers that that um
you know joined us as she went through
the school uh the way that the demons
you know had come in they had come when
she was 5 years old uh you know and um
you know they she had grown up watching
pornography uh you know there was um
father was kind of porn uh pornography
addict and uh you know it was second
nature for her so uh to help her the
Holy Spirit led us through this long
journey but eventually open up our eyes
to the fact she needed to give up her
phone and her laptop and so for the last
two years as she has been having Victory
uh you know from that pivotal moment
when we took away the phone and the
laptop uh she just changed you know
overnight and month by month she's just
been getting stronger and stronger and
stronger and um she's a completely
different person now after about a year
a year and a half I love it I love it
that's the power of the Gospel it can
change you that's right you know and so
you have to look at where the holy
spirit is telling you to get rid of
things uh and then the third one is
learning how to use the word of God as a
weapon right too many many of us we we
know how to study the Bible might even
know how to memorize it but we're not
using it as a weapon against the enemy
and so we need to learn how to rebuke
the enemy in Zechariah 3:2 it says the
Lord rebuke thee of Satan and that story
is about how Joshua is there the high
priest and he's bowing before God and
the devil's there accusing him right and
trying to attack him and then Jesus
comes and he says the Lord rebuke thee
of Satan which means that uh you know
when we use Bible texts we can command
these demons to leave right in the name
of Jesus and so we can claim Zechariah
3:2 and say Lord you know the demons are
attacking me uh I claim Zechariah 3:2
the Lord rebuke thee Oh Satan in the
name of Jesus a command you evil spirits
to leave MH right and they have to leave
MH if you have that sincerity of heart
and you're dealing with your open doors
um they will
leave yeah wow so these are the
three-step process you know what uh you
your thoughts are not your thoughts what
are the open doors in your life confess
it and then learn to use the weapons of
warfare wow thank you for being so open
and honest and sharing I know what what
was a difficult beginning but I know
you've helped so many people in this um
let our audience know where can they
find you do you have a YouTube channel
website like if they want to learn more
how do they get in contact with you sure
yeah we we have a website um that you
know we'll put up on the screen uh for
sea salt um so it's uh
www.o
web.org aoi salt I believe so I'll put
the address on the screen um you can
also drop me an email at David AO
web.org um so that's David aoy web.org
or Sabrina at
music.org one word and de Brina tell us
a little bit about music verse because I
think this is a powerful thing as you
guys have talked about you know one
really simple way to begin to rewrite
this narrative that you have in your
head using the scriptures right so music
verse is meant to help people to um
focus on or help them in your spiritual
life so it's this platform for just only
Sacred Music and I compose scripture
songs and uh we have song books over
there that you can learn with the audio
guides and even the instrumentals and
we'll teach you how to sing and some of
the songs that are in there are actually
meant for deliverances and I just to
share little story um I was with a um
roommate that is dealing with a lot of
demon possession and harassment and she
would always get possessed every
sometimes every week and so God
impressed me and my other friend to
compose a song and that's taken from um
John first John uh which says peace I
live with you my peace I give unto you
and the other one is John 1427 oh yeah
John and the other one was fear thou not
for I am with the no uh first John 4:18
right yeah and so we combined those two
verses together and one day she was
harassed in her sleep and she woke up
screaming and I called my other friend
called her to pray with her and we sang
the song that we compos especially for
her and when we as soon as we sang that
song she immediately like we could see
peace in the face she got really calm
and she was able to go back to sleep and
this has helped her and many other
people who struggles with anxiety
depression and even spiritual warfare
and we have seen over the years how
powerful scripture turned into music and
uh that that is our missions to help
people in their own walk with God and
also as a weapon to fight against e the
evil fores so that's what our mission in
music vers is also and I think it's so
cool because like Psalms right they're
all they're all music pieces right yeah
I would love I can't wait to get to
heaven and actually hear like what did
that song sound like when you Sayang
that you know cuz some of them are
pretty interesting but um you have an
app yes music verse yes you bring bring
up a really excellent point if you have
anxiety you have trouble sleeping here
is a really great way to fall asleep put
it on the background exactly you know
listen to it as you drive around and and
and I I I I do I like the the Daniel
test right do a Daniel challenge do it
for 10 days download it 10 days see what
it does to you and you I I I stand firm
on that I guarantee you it will change
your life yes that's right yeah yeah
we've seen that not only just for
spiritual warfare but for the last I
would say 10 10 years now our church we
sing nothing but scripture songs and and
hymns so hymns for divine service but
outside of that whether it's small
groups or Vespers or afternoon uh we
just sing scripture songs and we've seen
how that has really
prepared you know families children
young people to have a greater desire to
study God's word amen so I really
believe that you know SC scripture songs
has that impact on also preparing our
hearts to love God's word as well amen
thank you you guys so much for coming on
and sharing with us I know I'm excited
about the next couple times we get a
chance to chat so um thank you for being
open and honest and we hope you guys had
a blessing please share this video with
somebody if if you know somebody that's
struggling with this and they need help
just as a as a kind gesture hey I came
across this video this might help you
out share it because it does no good
just sitting in in in in the computer
and not getting out there and uh a
simple way that you can do to also
support the work that we do give it a
thumbs up give it a um subscribe if you
have never subscribed to our channel
before that really helps us push these
things out there in in the algorithms
and um please pray for David and
Sabrina's Ministries these guys are out
there on the front lines doing amazing
work and um keep them in your prayers
look them up and um watch some of the
material that they've got going on check
out music verse I guarantee you it'll
change your life and we want to thank
you guys so much for watching we'll see
you next
week created you oh
Jacob and he form you oh
Israel I will make him a killer in the
temple of my God and he shall go out no
more I will ride on him the name of my
God strong in the Lord and in the
power shall your strength
[Music]
shall alone but by every word of that
proceeds from the mouth of God
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
w
[Music]
[Applause]
a
[Music]
oh